some people really like their iPhones
some people wish they were a little
bigger guess what this is the iPhone
six-plus and it is a big sucker it has a
five and a half inch display and let me
hold up my old iPhone 5s just for
comparison my phone is smaller than this
phone's entire display it has 2 million
pixels in that display it is a retina HD
display but the phone is actually
thinner than the previous iPhone 5s it
is 7.1 millimeters as opposed to seven
point six millimeters this new screen
allows you to see more when you're
looking online and that file has
incorporated some clever tricks because
one of the problems with a very large
display is how do you get your thumb
from here to there if you're not Andre
the Giant well what you can do is you
can actually just double tap on the home
screen and the contents of that screen
comes down so you can reach all around
the phone will be available for
pre-order on September 12th then sold in
stores on September 19th
it starts at $1.99 for 16 gigabytes
$2.99 for 64 gigabytes and 399 for a new
128 gigabyte threshold